[Music]
in
every esport there are those truly sick
superstars whose inhuman achievements
everyone not only admires
but every once in a while seeks to
imitate
you've probably found yourself chilling
below b apps up in hand
thinking to yourself i'ma be coldzera
real quick
that worked that's a
cold zero jump shot that's literally
this
or maybe you're a hot shot who knows the
daigo parry
so well that you can recreate it without
even looking at the screen
[Applause]
but in the world of rainbow six siege
there is one warrior whose worship has
walloped the rest a truly
cracked killer who went from dumpstering
plebs online to winning
major esports titles of course i'm
talking about the
ever impersonated jason bolo
doty a living breathing aimbot whose
twitchy
lean intensive playstyle hasn't just
become the envy of seizures everywhere
but for many the end goal
but as much as bolo's absurd ability to
frag has created excitement around siege
and
elevated the skill sealing of the game
it's also created a bit of a problem
you see by sheer accident he's inspired
just about every g
fueled zoomer with an r4c in a prime
subscription to play
just like him even when they can't
four years later 19 pro player playing
the game you know how it should be
against people that were like it's
basically like the
14 year old bolos i'm playing against 15
year old bolos i'm like
wow this this [ __ ] sucks so
how did bolo create this cult of lean
spamming clones
how has his playstyle kind of thrown
siege into an identity crisis
and long term will it hurt or
help the game
oh my god that [ __ ] mirror is open
what the [ __ ] who opened this mirror
okay so if you are unfamiliar with my
boy boiler then
well you've clearly never watched any of
our siege content because this little
ray of sunshine
rakes in the views for us he's a wildly
talented
youtuber turned world-class competitor
who spent years
making a name for himself by
embarrassing siege's
sweatiest tryhards
five seconds
[Music]
and in 2019 after overcoming criticism
cheating allegations and a crazy amount
of pressure
he became everything that he his fans
and the community at large
hoped he would a successful pro player
they
know that these guys are going to be
extended in the kitchen i think tsm
might overextend
through office and out of nowhere bolo's
just in the site
what is going on how is he even able to
enter now he's got control
hopefully oh the bomb is go the bomb is
being planted out of nowhere
tsm making an aggressive rush in a rush
plant this might work out for tsm
sexy will take down two there but a
trade-off from bolo now we stand at a
3v3 in the post plant scenario
another one rotating down but paulie
will get one bola with three on the
round now looking for more
it's down to the 2v2 sexy cake and psk
collapsing from the blue bar in the
kitchen area
trying to bring in some yokai drones
drones in the attacking side being sent
out as well
although not spotting the yokai coming
closer and closer to jaws music
amplifies
but now in the hallway that's four for
polo will he get the ace turning the
corner give it to him
let's go give him the ace put it in the
montage tsm
of 2-0 but we're not here to talk about
bolo's incredible rise to the top
we are here to talk about his play style
and the
legion of feral fanboys who've basically
started
a religion around it you see what made
bolo such a
viral sensation to begin with were his
other
worldly mechanics now for those who've
never had the pleasure of watching him
play
it's sort of like the aurora borealis or
watching an ash mane destroy a single
piece of utility
you just won't believe it until you see
it
that's the fuser
[Music]
that is a high quality stream youtube
[Music]
clip
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
tracy
[Music]
for a game that was slow methodical and
utility oriented
bolo was an anomaly a blood
berserker who went burr in a way that
nobody really had before
i was young at the time so i didn't have
a huge attention span
you know do the whole teamwork stuff i
kind of just ran in i was used to
playing call of duty ran in
just kind of flick all over the place
see if i can get a you know a one for
one maybe a two for one and
and then i was dead and i was happy but
of all the things that encompassed
bolo's
exhilarating artistry none were as
fabled
and frustrating as the so-called
bolo leaning
the whole bolo ling kind of happened
pretty organically if you even look
through like my
early montages very slow really just
like
rough like my crosstalk placement's not
good the leaning is not good
and then once you get deeper and deeper
you start to see it kind of come
together like they're really fast doing
like 50 leans in like two seconds
something like that but
i didn't just sit there and like
practice it i just kind of you know
i mean i was you know 15 16 i just
wanted to peak as fast as possible
10 seconds to go i broke from the
operator
and it was that quick corner popping
pornography
that really started to catch the
attention of the community
from seasoned professionals
[Music]
to filthy casuals what
what killed me blackbeard oh he was in
that side hatch i didn't even see him
what the [ __ ] i got a headshot one
friendly
[Music]
looks like i know where he has to be
he's [ __ ] hacking dude
the bolo peak had cemented itself as
the badass yet blood-boiling bane of
seizures everywhere sure it was skillful
and required insane amounts of practice
to perfect
but due to things like net code server
refresh rate
and ping it was basically uncountable
definitely thinking like the i guess
prime time quick peeking bolo lean
era along with the servers you would get
ghosts a lot like you would see somebody
quick peek you and then they're already
gone
and then you're dead i could see how
frustrating it would be
being on the opposing end and it wasn't
long before bolo started to catch the
attention
of ubisoft you don't even have to
explain to me exactly
the way below play and we know that's
the thing we're very well aware
i'm not personally good enough to face
this player 24
7. like i'm flat and it's not enough to
be honest to face the most extreme cases
on a daily basis
i do see some of them and like even
people from lower rank
try to do it it's just just not as good
and it is definitely something we have
on our radar
bolo hadn't just elevated siege's skill
ceiling
he'd pushed the game to its very limits
and whether inadvertently or not
he was punished for it in the spring of
2018 when ubisoft
sneakily hot fixed lean spamming come on
we're gonna do that
it's just like
dude they just like chop my legs off did
kind of you know
feel like i was being targeted it was
kind of like this
monster child i created um and it was
just kind of you know spawning in the
thousands of thousands it was just
taking over the game like the plateau
range with like all the ashes and
everything
so i think it was kind of more of like a
collective effort from the depth just to
you know kind of clean up the game a
little bit again just
kind of make the way uh siege is meant
to be played in their eyes
now unfortunately for ubisoft their
attempt at squashing this mechanic
didn't quite go to plan what's more bolo
was
simply too nutty to nerf
if you remain in this zone
that's a habana in a boom you will be
detected
like i kind of noticed that uh like
mechanically
like all like a bunch of pro league
players at the time just you know
weren't there obviously they are now but
like
i definitely was kind of you know
maximizing my mechanical ability rather
than you know
trying to play the game how it was meant
to be played within no time
bolo's breakneck balls to the wall play
style
had become the go-to rhythm of basically
every kid to come within a country mile
of a ranked server
from your everyday matchmaking scrub
no i want to become bolo to some truly
godly successors
apparently not siege's player base was
showing little interest in emulating
actual world champions since those dudes
played actual siege
instead they saw this teenager tearing
up sights in seconds flat and thought
that's what i want to do i want to go to
there
here's the thing though that style of
siege
isn't really sustainable outside of
matchmaking
even for an aim god like bolo i think
like for all like the clones like even
like the content creator clones i guess
you would like you know replicate the
play style that you were talking about
i think it's possible for you know a lot
of them to go pro it's just like
it's it's it's really hard it's
unbelievable how much you have to
discipline yourself from going from
ranked
to comp and it's all up to bolo in a 1v2
ramp very low and bolo appears to be a
little bit lost with 30 seconds left
volts had full hp three still three stim
pistols and bolo's been felled by a good
one and as he tries to withstand
oh find another when i first
joined the team i was definitely you
know that kind of ranked play style i
overpeaked a lot of things i kind of
just
jumped the gun on a lot of stuff and i'm
just
baffled that space station didn't say
hey
check it if nothing else oh
ho-ho fultz picking up his second kill
of this game as
down goes bolo the reality is that even
the
buello had to curb his hyperactive
playstyle in order to succeed at the
highest level of play
and fortunately for him that's exactly
what he did
so they do have the ability to punch out
oh and this guy's down bolo finds two
and he's gonna be a 1v2 now in addition
to being one of siege's most
highly rated pros he's already won a lan
a major and come within breathing
distance of taking home
the big one there's no denying that he's
found success on the world stage
but if he hadn't learned to adjust he
might not have
even though like top three i'm not happy
with that top three i want to you know i
want to be the top one
the one but um i do feel
pretty proud of myself on how far i've
come because i could have
i could have not changed and we could
have you know we could have gotten
relegated and i would have been back to
streaming and youtube
full-time and that would have been the
end of uh tsm bolo
because in spite of what all these
snotty ash spammers with their bolo
charms
amethyst skins and purple attachments
would have you believe
bolo leans aren't the be-all and end-all
of rainbow six
even if they do make you feel like a
badass you have about a half hour from
now until the matchup starts so you can
go and you can
yeah yeah yeah you get the lpms though
yeah i get that
look no one would deny that bolo flicks
are swanky as hell
and god knows they're capable of
stopping even the
gnarliest of gunners dead in their
tracks
but you know what's even better at doing
that
reinforcing a [ __ ] wall
one book's
yeah you're good now i tried i tried my
best
and sure is it true that the game has
become a little
too utility oriented as of late
undeniably
but siege isn't cs go gunning
isn't everything and you shouldn't be
able to weasel your way out of having a
brain
simply because the game isn't capable of
keeping up with how fast you're spamming
yourself in and out of cover
at some point that kind of thing needs
to be stifled and while they have taken
steps towards doing that
the issue remains a contentious one even
at ubisoft
because it's more something like we see
something that we discuss something we
argue about and that we might not all
agree with
and so i can't really give you a
definite answer some people
think it's like a very high skill
setting that you need to master in
school
other things like the angelman there for
the game i understand both point of view
and we will find out exactly where we
stand it's too
long-term and it's too much about an
ongoing conversation
more than a definitive direction that we
have look in spite of all the things
that separate siege from a traditional
shooter it remains just that
a shooter the importance of gunplay
can't be overstated
in any fps the difference with siege
is that for a long time that importance
went
understated and in many ways it wasn't
until bolo came along and started
terrorizing people that it became
apparent
just how far gunning alone could get you
i
definitely definitely think that you
know your mechanical skill and your i
guess
gun skill overall is crucial because
even though
right now the utility meta that we're in
is just heavily soaked and just you know
get rid of this get rid of that
last 20 seconds is when you finally see
action you know those 20 seconds you're
gonna
want to hit your shots there's a reason
we all fell in love with bolo to begin
with and
frustrating as the style he's
trademarked has become
doing away with it entirely wouldn't
just suck
it would destroy the very soul of siege
you try
clearing in bolo shield when he's got
three ads's and five will my magnets can
you try throwing those flashbangs well
he's like this
bro he does not miss because ultimately
that's what makes siege such an engaging
esport
the chaos and the uncertainty is it a
moba
sure a shooter most definitely hell it's
even a fighting game from time to time
truly there is no one way to play
rainbow six
you can be whoever you want and clap
people
however you please and bolo was a
testament to that
so look if you want to wear out your q e
buttons
go for it really just know that you
won't be bad
if you don't play the game your way
because you want to that's what keeps it
evolving
that's what keeps it fun i guess my
message to
all the uh like the bolo lean
you know copycats and all the quick
peeking ashes though
players i mean just do whatever you want
i don't really care
just have fun with the game it is a game
at the end of the day it sucks that i
have to play my 15 year old self now
whenever i stream but
um it's just i guess that's just how it
goes the monster child is uh
in full force
cult of lean spamming clones how is this
yeah this little bastard just rakes in
the views for us i wanted to write this
line because i knew that there was going
to be some
her in the comments who was just like
you know it's like with olaf boost it's
like oh score esports need
a few quota this month like make bolo
videos so i was just like
it's off me let's just lean into it like
let's just yeah